Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sama sambuddhasa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So the question this evening is, did the Buddha believe in God?
Did Buddha believe in a God?
Or was he an atheist, a non-theist, a non-creator theist, or an agnostic?
and from this another question arises is buddhism is the teaching of the buddha a religion or is it not so uh first of all to understand the buddhist position we have to put aside the abrahamic god of the of the jews the christians and the muslims
First of all, to understand the position of Buddha, we have to put aside the mythical God Abraham of the Jews, Christians and Muslims.
So, that Abrahamic God, he created the world and he also created the moral order, so he can punish and reward depending on our behaviour.
This Abrahamic God is the one who created the world and established the rules and therefore can punish or reward.
So in the West we have this atheism which is a little bit aggressive against this omnipotent, omniscient and omnipresent God.
There is atheism
in the West, which is quite aggressive, because it opposes the notion of a omnipotent, omniscient, omnipresent God.
So they base their understanding on scientific materialism.
These atheists are based on a science-based criticism.
So we can safely say that the Buddha never talked about this sort of God.
In fact, I don't think it arises in the Indian tradition.
I think the Buddha never talked about this type of God.
and no other Indian traditions.
So in the Brahminical system there was Brahma the creator, Vishnu the preserver, and Shiva the destroyer.
In the Brahminical tradition there was Brahma the creator, Vishnu the preserver,
and the lord of karma was just in that in that mix uh sorry the lord the lord of karma was included in that uh creation the lord of karma yeah the lord of karma alleging
The Law of Karma was included in this vision.
So it wasn't that God either punished or rewarded you, there was the Lord of Karma.
so there are many other types of theisms pantheism panentheism polytheism even though in the scriptures they talk about the devas the gods these can be seen more like angels
Nelle scritture si parla dei devas.
I don't know this word.
Ah, devas, ok. Nelle scritture si parla dei devas, cioè degli dèi, ma nessuno di questi ha il potere sopra il mondo, il potere di creazione.
They're more like angels.
Sono più come degli angeli.
The Buddha definitely was not an agnostic.
Buddha infine non era assolutamente un agnostico.
He doesn't say anywhere that he cannot decide whether there's a god or not because he hasn't got enough information.
In fact, the idea of God just simply doesn't arise in his teachings.
So in this sense he can be called a non-theist.
There just simply isn't the mention of a God in that sense.
We also have a similar situation with Taoism.
So the Tao is seen as maybe the ground of being, but there's no personal God or anything like that.
There were other questions that the Buddha didn't answer.
He would not go beyond what can be personally experienced.
So for instance, is the cosmos eternal or not eternal?
Is it finite or infinite?
So he doesn't answer that, yeah?
He says it's not determined.
Another question was, is the body the same as the everlasting soul or is the body one thing and the everlasting soul something else?
Another question was, is the body the same as an eternal soul
So the objection here would be the definition of a soul.
And so he didn't answer that.
And then there are the four questions to do with the Buddha himself.
And then the four questions that have to do with the Buddha himself.
Does the Tathagata, the Buddha, exist after death or does he not exist?
Does he both exist and not exist?
or does he neither exist nor not exist so this was known as the quadrilemma so we have a dilemma this is the quadrilemma and he didn't answer
Now, in those days, on the moon nights, the teachers would come to these shrines, which were like beautiful parks.
In those days, on full moon days, the teacher would go to these shrines, which were also very beautiful parks.
And they would argue their different doctrines against each other.
The Buddha wouldn't go to them.
He said it was a thicket of views, a wilderness of views, a contortion of views, a writhing of views, a fetter of views.
He said about these occasions that they are a juniper of points of view, a jungle of points of view, a node of points of view, a contortion, a chain of points of view.
It is accompanied by suffering, distress, despair and fever, and it does not lead to disenchantment, dispassion, cessation, to calm, direct knowledge, full awakening, nibbāne.
And so, all this is accompanied by suffocation, anguish, despair, fever, does not lead to disenchantment, detachment, cessation,
So does this mean that there is no teaching about transcendence in the Buddhadhamma?
Many times he talks about Nibbāna as a transcendental experience, something beyond the body and mind.
So now we are going to read this discourse
which is where the buddha really makes fun of the idea of a creator god but goes on to tell us that there is a transcendent state
But then he continues by saying that there is a transcendental state.
Okay, so this discourse is known as the discourse about Kevada.
He's a monk.
This discourse is known as the Kevada discourse.
I don't know how to pronounce it.
And he's a monk.
A monk.
Kevada.
So this is his question.
Where do the four primary elements cease completely
namely the element of the earth, water, fire and air.
In other words, the material world, where is it annihilated?
This is the question.
Where do the four primary elements, earth, water, fire and air, completely disappear?
In other words, where is the material world annihilated?
so he approaches the various realms of the god firstly the four kings but they don't know they send him to the gods of the 33 and they in turn to the gods of yama and so on to the suyama gods the joyful gods the gods of santis tusita the gods who delight in creation all the way up to the gods of brahma host even they say they don't know but great brahma will
So, at this point he goes on to ask the various kingdoms of the gods.
So there are the four great kings, but they don't know it, and they send him to the gods of the 33, and in turn they send him to the gods of Yama, and then to the gods of Suyama, the joyful gods, the gods called Santussita,
the gods who delight in creation, and the gods who follow Brahma.
They say they don't know, but the great Brahma will.
And it was not long before the great Brahma became manifest, and that monk drew near to him and said, Where, friend, do the four great elements, earth, water, fire, and wind, cease without remainder?
and when he had thus spoken the great brahma said to him monk i am the great brahma the supreme the mighty the all-seeing the ruler the lord of all the controller the creator the chief of all appointing each to his place the ancients of days the father of all that is and is to be then that monk said to brahma i did not ask you friend as to whether you were the great brahma the supreme and mighty the all-seeing the ruler the lord etc etc
I want to know where do the four great elements, earth, water, fire and wind cease without remainder?
And the great Brahma said to him, I am the great Brahma, the supreme and mighty, the all-seeing, the ruler, the lord of all, the controller, the creator, the chief of all, appointing each to his place, the ancient of days, the father of all that is and is to be.
And then again, the third time Kevara said,
i didn't ask you friend as to whether you were the great brahma the supreme the mighty and so on and so forth i wanted to know where do the great elements earth water fire and wind cease and cease without remainder allora poco dopo appare brama il monaco si avvicina al grande brama e gli chiese
Friend, where do these four great elements cease without return?
The great Brahma said to the monk, I, monk, am Brahma, the great Brahma, the conqueror, the unconquered, the omnipotent, the sovereign lord, the creator of all that has been and will be.
And a second time the monk said to the great Brahma, my friend, I have not asked you if you are Brahma, the great Brahma, the conqueror, the unconquered, the omnivore, the omnipotent, the sovereign Lord, the creator of all that has been and will be.
I have asked you where these four great elements cease without return.
And a second time, the great Brahma replied to the monk, I, the monk, am Brahma, the great Brahma, the conqueror, the unconquered, the omnipotent, the omnipotent, the sovereign Lord, the creator of all that has been and will be.
Now the great Brahma took that monk by the arm and led him aside and said, these gods, these devas of the retinue of Brahma,
believe there is nothing i cannot see nothing i have not understood nothing i have not realized therefore i gave no answer in their presence
i do not know monk where these four elements earth water fire and wind cease without remainder therefore monk you have done wrong have acted unwisely in that ignoring the exalted one the buddha you have undertaken this long search among others for an answer to this question go now return to the exalted one and ask him the question and accept the answer he gives you
So, Brahma responds, leading the monk away, he said to him, These gods of Brahma's followers believe that there is nothing that the great Brahma does not know, there is nothing that the great Brahma does not see, there is nothing that the great Brahma does not know, there is nothing that the great Brahma has not realized.
That is why I did not say in their presence that even I do not know where these four great elements cease without return.
And so you, oh monk, you acted badly, you acted not wisely, because ignoring the blessed, the Buddha, you have undertaken this long search
So Kevāda finds the Buddha and asks him the same question and the Buddha corrects him, saying the question should be asked like this.
Where do earth, water, fire and air find no footing?
Where are long and short, small and great, fair and foul?
Where are the body and mind brought to an end?
So Kevada goes back to Buddha and asks him the same question.
But Buddha corrects him and says, the question should be posed like this.
Where is the earth?
So the Buddha's answer now refers to the body, the mind and consciousness.
there is a consciousness that is non-manifestive limitless and all luminous here water earth fire and wind find no footing here long and short small and large pleasant and unpleasant here matter and mind are all brought to an end with the cessation of consciousness this is all brought to an end
Buddha's answer concerns the body, the mind and consciousness.
The answer is this.
There is a consciousness that is non-manifest, unlimited and completely luminous.
Here, water, earth, fire and wind do not find support.
And here, long, short, small, big, pleasant and unpleasant, here matter and mind are all brought to Earth.
With the cessation of consciousness, all this is brought to Earth.
So here we have a very clear statement.
The first consciousness is the transcendent, having no boundary and no objects.
It is unconditioned, not depending on anything outside itself.
And so here we have a very clear statement.
The first consciousness is the transcendent, which has no boundaries, no objects.
The second consciousness cannot be the same because that comes to an end.
This is the consciousness of the five khandhas, the five aggregates, the body and mind.
This is the consciousness that operates within the mind, constantly arising and passing away, dependent on the sense-bases.
Hence the Buddha talks of eye-consciousness, ear-consciousness and so on.
The second consciousness cannot be the same because it comes to the earth.
This is the consciousness of the five khandhas, the five aggregates,
of the body and the mind.
This is the consciousness that operates in the mind, that constantly arises and vanishes, regardless of the basis of the senses.
In fact, Buddha speaks of the consciousness of the eye, the consciousness of the ear, and so on.
The visual and auditory consciousness.
So, returning to our other question,
can can you have a religion without a god is the buddha dharma a religion so the answer depends upon whether you believe in a god or not and whether that means that it's a religion
If, however, you define religion as teaching that there is a transcendent, non-changing reality beyond the material and mental worlds, then it is a religion.
If the answer depends on whether you believe in a god or not, then this is not a religion.
But if, instead,
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance that they have not caused confusion.
And that your devotion to the practice and the Eightfold Path, that you will be liberated from suffering sooner rather than later.